I've told you multiple times that the
derivative of a curve at a point is the
slope of the tangent line but our friend
Akash sent me a problem where it
actually wants you to find the equation
of the tangent line and I realize I've
never actually done that so I it's it's
worthwhile to let's do that so it says
find the equation of the tangent line to
the function f of X is equal to X e to
the X at X is equal to 1 so let's just
get an intuition of what we're even
looking for so this function is going to
look something like I actually graphed
it it's not a trivial function to graph
so this is X e to the X this is what it
looks like just use the graphing
calculator and you can see I just typed
it in and what this is asking us is okay
at the point X is equal to 1 so this is
the point X is equal to 1 so f of X is
going to be someplace up here and
actually f of X is going to be equal to
e right because write f of f of 1 is
equal to what 1 times e to the 1 so it
equals e so we're saying at the point at
the point 1 comma e so at the point 1
comma 2 point 7 1 whatever whatever so
that's what point that's this point so
it's right here to point this is e right
here the point 1 comma e so what we want
to do is figure out the equation of the
line tangent to this point so we're
going to do is we're going to solve it
by figuring out its slope which is just
the derivative at that point so we have
to figure out the derivative at exactly
this point and then we use what we
learned from algebra 1 to figure out its
equation and then we'll graph it here
just to confirm that we've actually
figured out the equation of the tangent
line so the first thing we want to know
is the slope of the tangent line and
that's just the derivative at this point
exit at the when X is equal to 1 or at
the point 1 comma e so what's the
derivative of this so f prime of X F
prime of X is equal to well this looks
like a a job for the product rule
because we know how to figure out the
derivative of X we don't have to figure
out the derivative of e to the X and
there
multiplying by each other so the product
rule tells us the river of this thing is
going to be equal to the derivative of
the first expression of the first
function so the derivative of X is just
1 times the second function times e to
the X plus the first function x times
the derivative of the second function so
what's the derivative of e to the X and
that's what I find so amazing about the
number E or the function e to the X is
the derivative of e to the X is e to the
X the slope at any point of this curve
is equal to the value of the function so
this is the derivative so what is the
derivative of this function at the point
X is equal to 1 or at the point 1 comma
e so we just evaluate it we say F prime
of 1 is equal to 1 times e to the 1 plus
1 times e to the 1 well that's just
equal to e plus e see then well that's
just equal to 2e you know we could
figure out what that know you know e is
just a constant number but we write e
because it's easier to write E then 2.7
cetera et cetera and an infinite number
of digits so we just write to e so this
is the slope of the equation or this is
the slope of the curve when X is equal
to 1 or at the point 1 e or 1 F of 1 so
what is the equation of the tangent line
so it's going to take this form the
equation is going to be y is equal to
I'm just writing it in the you know the
point not the point slope the MX plus B
form for what you learned in algebra so
the slope is going to be 2 e we just
learned that here that's the derivative
when X is equal to 1 so 2 2 e times X
plus the y-intercept so if we can figure
out the y-intercept with this line we
are done we have figured out the
equation of the tangent line so how do
we do that well if we knew a Y or X
where that this equation goes through we
could then solve for B and well we know
a Y in X where that satisfies this
equation the point 1 comma e the point
where we're trying to find the tangent
line right
so this point one comma E this is where
we want to find to the tangent line and
by definition the tangent line is going
to go through that point so let's
substitute that those points back in
here or at this point back into this
equation and then solve for B so Y is
equal to e is equal to 2e that's just
the slope at that point times X times 1
plus B it might confuse you because e
you'll say oh that e is that a variable
no it's the number remember it's like PI
it's a number you could substitute 2.7
whatever there but we're not doing that
because this is cleaner and let's solve
so you get e is equal to 2 e plus B
let's subtract 2e from both sides we get
B is equal to e minus 2e B is equal to
minus E now we're done what's the
equation of the tangent line it is y is
equal to 2 times e X plus B but B is
minus C so it's minus e so this is the
equation of the tangent line if you
don't like these ease there you can
replace that with a number two point
seven etc and this would become 5 point
something and this would just be minus
two point seven something but this looks
neater and let's confirm let's use our
this little graphing calculator to
confirm that that really is the equation
of the tangent line so let me type it in
here so it's it's two two times e times
X right that's 2e X minus E and let us
graph this line there we go it graphed
it and you notice that that line that
green line I don't know if you can maybe
I need to make this bigger for it to
show up bolder I don't know if that
helps but if you look here so this red
this is our original equation X e to the
X that's this curve we want to know the
tange the
the equation of the tangent line at X is
equal to 1 so it's the point X is equal
to 1 and when X is equal to 1 f of X is
e right you could just substitute back
into the original equation to get that
so it's this is the point 1 comma e so
the equation of the tangent line its
slope is going to be the derivative at
this point so we solved the derivative
of this function and evaluated it at X
is equal to 1 that's what we did here we
figured out the derivative evaluated at
X equal 1 and so we said ok the slope
the slope at when X is equal to 1 and Y
is equal to e the slope at that point is
equal to 2e and we figured that out from
the derivative and then we just use our
algebra 1 skills to figure out the
equation of that line and how did we do
that well we just we knew the slope
because that's just the derivative at
that point and then we just have to
solve for the y-intercept and the way we
did that is we said well the point 1
comma e is on this green line as well so
we substituted that in and solve for our
y-intercept which we got is minus E and
notice that this line intersects the
y-axis at minus a this about minus 2
point 7 something and there we have it
we have shown that and visually it shows
that this is the tangent line anyway
hope you found that vaguely useful I you
did you should thank akaash for being
unusually persistent and having me do
this problem see you in the next video